another great job babe
kiddo babe you gotta condition that long
hair we got enough split ends Hello whoa
whoa not again
oh no what
did I killed Jamaica now I love you too
dog for kids program see you in the
postseason brick
oh it's a physical sport next man up CMC
Drive slay this Santa Claus seems like
it's on very shaky legal ground no
[Music]
you're in charge of Distributing the
footballs now forever we don't like to
think about next year here in Santa
Clara Debo will help you with anything
you need oh great more things for me to
do and this is Bosa our sack Master suck
my cheat codes are more photogenic and
my voice is deeper oh no is this a
Horror Story look it happens all the
time see I guess I gotta buy some shoes
to fill oh boy this is a rough game
Don't Mind If I Do black ho ho ho look
who's came crawling back I didn't even
get her hurt keep an eye on the internal
clock in the sleigh you have three
seconds to deliver each ball nothing
over five yards okay Brock
Jingle Bell Jing
jingle around the hey he does exist he
does exist